Північ Німеччини, узбережжя Балтійського моря.
Німецькі екологи побоюються, що морське середовище цього регіону -
під загрозою через будівництво російського газопроводу
"Північний потік-2".
Німецьке екологічне об'єднання Nabu
вказує на те, що в територіальних водах Німеччини
трубопровід повністю проходитиме через
морські природоохоронні зони.
Балтійське море надзвичайно активно експлуатується.
Особливість ситуації полягає в тому, що це закрите море,
тобто в нього надходить мало свіжої води, багатої на кисень.
А через прокладання труб з дна моря
підніметься дуже багато різноманітних речовин.
Лише фосфору - 250 тон
у Поморській бухті та в районі Грайфсвальда.
Ці речовини призведуть до активного цвітіння морської води.
Для розкладання водоростей знадобиться дуже багато кисню,
якого в Балтійському морі і так не вистачає.
Як наслідок, рівень кисню знизиться до такого рівня,
що багато морських тварини і рослини просто загинуть.
Ситуацією стурбовані й екологи в Росії.
У російському офісі Грінпіс впевнені, що прокладання труби
завдасть непоправної шкоди Кургальскому заказнику -
одному з двох найбільших заказників Ленінградської області.
Він з єдиної компактної території перетвориться на територію,  яка розбита.
Там практично на трасі знаходиться велике гніздо
орлана-білохвоста,  де він виводить пташенят.
Це підтверджено дослідженнями.
І, звичайно, воно буде втрачене.
До того ж досить багато видів рослин, лишайників,
зокрема, з Червоної книги Росії і Ленінградської області.
Грінпіс підтримують і деякі учасники
громадської екоекспертизи "Північного потоку-2".
На німецькій частині траса йде під землю,
тунелями, тобто мінімізує шкоду лісовій території.
А у нас не найкращі технології, а найгірші -
найбільш потворним траншейним методом,
та ще й на природній території, що особливо охороняється.
На думку "Грінпіс Росії", компанія Нордстрім
обрала простіший маршрут через бажання заощадити
і не вести газопровід альтернативним шляхом.
Хоча була можливість прокласти трубу на півдні заказника,
ближче до кордону з Естонією.
У Нордстрім ці звинувачення відкидають.
Траса знаходиться у південній, вузькій, периферійній частині заказника.
Про поділ території заказника на дві частини не йдеться.
Коридор будівництва газопроводу на сухопутній ділянці зачепить
близько 0,10% території.
На місці встановлення газопроводу суттєво скоротять
використання важкого обладнання,
що дозволить знизити рівень шуму і пов'язаний з ним
вплив на етапі будівництва.
На думку німецьких екологів з Nabu,
проект не відповідає вимогам незалежної процедури видачі дозволів,
скільки значної частини даних моніторингу впливу на довкілля
просто не було.